we all want to be normal but our picture
of what is normal is in fact really
unhelpful so many of the things we're
told that are weird are in fact
completely average and widespread for
example if you fear you've married the
wrong person
get sick with envy when a friend
succeeds fantasize about your wife
sister want to cry when anyone
criticizes you dislike the way you look
panic at thought of going to a party
worry a great deal about farting in
public feel you might vomit during a
meeting out of fear have ever had a
lustful thought about a member of your
own family bump your head while trying
to get into a taxi are turned on by some
pretty strange people or stories in the
news frequently visit adult websites
regard yourself as a fraud worried about
not making it to the bathroom in time
walk into doors lampposts rearview
mirrors and ballers worry that other
people can see your private parts still
think about a relationship that ended
badly 11 years ago
then you can quietly congratulate
yourself you are deeply normal we suffer
so much and so unnecessarily because our
picture of what is normal isn't true -
how most of us actually are we get
disgusted and ashamed of ourselves for
no reason there's nothing strange about
being compulsive manic anxious sexual
worried or mad being odd is normal and
that's okay it's become hard to say
anything especially on social media that
won't upset someone somewhere rather a
lot there's a myriad of